en tout cas frédéric ces deux
disparitions illustre bien le fait que
le burkina faso est aux prises avec une
période d'instabilité assez grave
oui céline c'est vraiment un pays qui
est fragilisée un pays évidemment de
l'amérique de l'afrique de l'ouest
évidemment bordée par la côte d'ivoire
ghana togo bénin mais surtout c'est au
nord c'est de là que vient à cette
menace évidemment c'est au mali ya une
menace aux djihadistes qui vraiment fait
beaucoup de problèmes beaucoup de vagues
dans ce pays notamment un groupe qui
s'appelle le gs im le gsm c'est en fait
le groupe de soutien à l'islam et aux
musulmans et c'est un groupe qui est né
un peu de la fusion de membres d'al
qaïda d'autres groupes également
jihadistes et donc on alimente beaucoup
en armes notamment des factions qui
commence à uvrer ici au burkina faso est
ce que le pays n'avait peut-être pas
prévu c'est qui est une autre menace
cette fois ci du côté de l'est
on est au niger et là encore une fois ce
sont les djihadistes cette fois ci c'est
le iie gsc l'état islamique dans le
grand sahara qui commence aussi à
vraiment attaqué à rentrer à nourrir
dans ces factions au burkina faso ce qui
fait évidemment que on a on assiste
vraiment une augmentation en fait des
attentats des frappes non seulement dans
certaines provinces un peu plus reculées
du pays mais aussi ça se passe aussi
dans la capitale ouagadougou il ya eu
plusieurs frappes
il ya une soixantaine de morts dans
trois attaques différentes ce qui fait
que depuis 2015 maintenant on dénonce on
dénombre déjà 270 morts parmi les
militaires et parmi les civils
il ya des écoles qui ont été fermés et
puis il ya aussi quarante mille
personnes déjà qu'ils ont été déplacées
à cause de cette menace djihadiste way
ces problèmes dans le pays c'est aussi
le résultat de changements politiques
depuis quelques années enfin depuis 2015
oui en fait ce qui est arrivé c'est que
ça c'était l'homme fort du burkina faso
blaise compaoré qui a régné vraiment
sans partage pendant 27 ans là bas et
quand monsieur compaoré est tombé mais
on peut dire qu'on a en quelque sorte un
peu négligé la sécurité
les militaires qui n'ont n'avait pas
beaucoup soit 2,2 de moyens techniques
pour aller combattre ces factions ce qui
fait que au bout du compte mais pendant
ce temps là on a les djihadistes yeux en
ont profité pour s'installer pour se
nourrir des frustrations de certaines
régions qui sont très très pauvre et de
faire des avancées comme ça dans le pays
ce qui fait que ça crée beaucoup
incertitude évidemment pour les
compagnies canadiennes comme on vous le
disait les compagnies évidemment
fortement minière les compagnies
aurifères par exemple il ya iamgold qui
est une compagnie c'est le plus gros
employeur privé là bas il ya aussi
semafo qui est au québec teranga aussi
et tout ça aussi créer un climat
d'incertitude cette fois ci pour l'aide
humanitaire canadienne qui est très
appliqué au burkina faso et toute cette
menace djihadiste évidemment via un peu
mêlé toutes les cartes avec encore donc
cette jeune et dit blé disparu depuis
décembre donc ensuite tout ça merci
frédéric r